stemis directed by Clint Eastwood get
off my lawn overuse quote I prefer this
one
you have Bounty Hunter man's gonna make
a living somehow
Diane ain't much of a living boy evil
surges society unwilling to learn from
the past
Jagger stars Leonardo DiCaprio Naomi
Watts
armie hammer and Judi Dench it's the
life story of the man who basically
founded and created what the FBI is
today he's the first guy who said hey we
should make fingerprints we should have
everyone fingerprinted we shouldn't be
able to not touch evidence we should
have a crime scene don't step there
don't touch that he's the first guy that
said that's how we're gonna solve cases
and murders and all that kind of stuff
he also led a very interesting and
whacked-out life we must never forget
our history
you must never know we're all God films
directed as I said my intro by clintus
oh there's one of my favorite directors
when my favorite actors favorite persons
in hollywood i've liked a lot of his
movies that he's made as well this one
is a lot more slower than most of his
films it's considerably slower than most
of his films it's also very long it's
like 2 hours and 17 minutes I also love
Leonardo DiCaprio is a great actor I
have sort of mixed thoughts on this film
a lot of people when they saw the
reviews for this film they were
surprised that they're kind of polarized
halfway mixed results that a lot of
these reviews are getting I'm gonna have
to agree with some of them I think the
jagger is a pretty good film i think it
could have been so much better really
the main issue with the movie is the
length it's extremely long and very
slow-paced to the point where it does
get very boring at times it's my belief
that when a man becomes a part of this
Bureau you must so conduct himself as to
eliminate in the slightest possibility
of criticism as to his conduct I tend to
actually appreciate slower paced films
more than the average film critic or
person or audience member would but
another issue I had at the film that I
thought made it not great was the fact
that it jumps times a lot it goes from
when he was older to when he was younger
20 was older and younger and the film is
not cohesive it just it seemed it felt
really sloppy the way it went from time
periods and it was difficult to follow
the story of when he was older it was
easier to follow the story when he was
younger and that seemed more like a good
story to tell and I feel like maybe
jumping to when he was older maybe
wasn't even necessary however the movie
is fairly good the reason I'm gonna say
that is because the film has very good
acting particularly from Leonardo
DiCaprio Naomi Watts as good as well but
she doesn't have much to do really
I mean she's good at what her role needs
but there's nothing terribly remarkable
about her character Judi Dench is
typically good in the film however Armie
Hammer who was in this social network
and very good in the social network I
feel is not Peck right here I feel he
was pretty over-the-top and I really
wasn't into his performance I just
didn't feel it when he was younger or
when he was older mr. Tolson I need
who I can trust I want you to be my
number two man you understand I need you
particularly when he was older because
with all the makeup which was very good
by the way
he didn't act like an old man he was
fast he moved fast it was until later in
the film that he started to actually act
like an old person and they really buy
him as an old person DiCaprio who ever
was very good in each part of the film I
think the film has some really strong
powerful emotional scenes as well
particularly when Leonardo DiCaprio has
to deal with some conflicts emotionally
inside his character that for that time
in America were not accepted imagine if
every citizen in this country when
uniquely identifiable body pattern on
their fingers again how quickly we could
find they committed a crime he goes
through a lot of scenes that are really
powerful and I found this character well
I seem like Eastwood told a story of him
very well it seemed like all the other
characters around him I just they felt
so unnecessary because it's just
difficult to balance when you jump from
time period so much you have to be right
on the money I think a really great
example of that is David Fincher's the
social network however the film is
directed well in that it looks very nice
the scenes are edited well acted very
well and there are some clever lines and
some good scenes and there are some
emotionally powerful scenes there are
definitely aspects of the film that I
was really into and things that it's not
a bad film at all it's just very
disappointing so I'm gonna have to give
j.edgar a b-minus
it's from his mother it's time this
generation of the difference between
villain
you
even great men can be corrupted if you
are a fan of DiCaprio if you're a fan of
Eastwood I would recommend checking it
out simply for them but it's not one of
their best films if you like this review
you can subscribe to my channel and get
stuck pronounced